Je construis quelque chose de
génial, ça a marché, je ne sais pas encore, nous vous avons donné
six ans et des millions de dollars et
vous ne nous avez rien donné de différent maintenant
Reed Richards,
il a développé un modèle entièrement fonctionnel,
il n'y a pas de plus grands esprits que ceux
de ce  chambre je dois dire que c'est amusant de vous avoir
ici vraiment vous avez craqué sur le
voyage interdimensionnel ensemble vous
pourriez changer le cours de l'histoire
vous êtes sûrs que vous êtes sur la meilleure forme pour être
fait ouais nous allons bien à cause d'un tragique
accident
les survivants tous  présenter
des conditions physiques uniques ces capacités
auront des applications infinies dans le monde réel
vous voulez dire la militarisation tout ce que je veux
savoir, c'est où sont mes enfants vous n'avez
aucune idée de ce qu'ils prévoient de
vous faire écoutez-moi c'est ce qui m'a amené ici
en premier lieu  je veux juste réparer mes
amis je ne peux pas réparer ça
personne ne peut
tu ne sais rien de ce qui se
passe ce qui va condamner la fin de ton
monde est le début du mien
sois plus fort que n'importe lequel d'entre nous mais il n'est pas
fort  plus que tout cela,
vous êtes prêts à vous faire exploser la tête,
dois-je alerter les pompiers